Hon var hemma hos mig, och jag ba, Jag ba, nej, nej, nej, nej, nej, nej, nej.
Nej, nej, nej.
Hon ba, joo...
Det får inte meningen.
Jag ba, okej, hade ni skydd?
Nämen asså...
Jag ba, tänker vi...
Make Sweden stronger.
Det är ett riktigt namn.
Exakt, exakt.
Det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt.
Det kör vi på.
Det får det bli.
Klart.
Då går vi vidare.
Kör vi på det.
Då välkomnar vi Anja Rahit i podden.
Och Anja är ju lite av ett unikum.
Hon har ju en riktigt, riktigt episk träningsanläggning på Avenyn i Göteborg.
Och hon har vunnit VM Silver i MMA.
Det är hyggligt.
Tackar.
Hej, hej.
Det var en fin intro.
Hej Joel.
Vi kanske ska säga att vi känner varandra lite så att det kommer låta lite mindre professionellt än vanligt.
Ja.
Ja, vi ska ändå försöka hålla någon sorts fokus i detta.
Men vi har känt varandra i ganska många år.
Ja, i typ femton, nej tolv.
Ja, tolv.
Vi träffades ju genom Kampsporten.
Och sen har jag faktiskt varit anställd hos dig under ett par år.
Mm, det var fina år det.
Ja, det var härliga år.
Det blev inte mycket gjort då.
Det kanske är bra att vi...
Vi tog grönt kort.
Ja, i golf.
Ja, det gjorde vi.
Jag tror aldrig att jag blev godkänd.
Jag tror att jag mutade till mig mitt kort.
Ja, alltså...
Jag vet att vi båda har det.
Men hur det gick till är helt obegripligt.
Nej.
Vi tog ju det för att vi skulle öppna ett gym även på en golfanläggning tillsammans.
Eller vi gjorde det, men den har vi inte längre.
Men skit i det, nu ska vi fokusera på dig och inte på oss.
Ja, vi dyker rätt in tänker jag.
Kan vi inte få höra lite hur du kom in i tränningsbranschen för du har inte alltid jobbat där.
Nej, absolut inte.
Jag var 23 och var personal och driftchef på ett café.
Och totalt sett rätt, beredd att göra vad som helst.
Köttade på mig livet och fest och träning och jobb och så.
Så blev jag headhuntad av någon som tyckte att jag verkade vara en bra säljare för att bli delägare i ett gym.
Men var du framförallt säljare på den tiden eller var du ändå inne i träningsvärlden?
Typ inte alltså.
Enligt mig själv så var jag ett fysiskt unikum men det var jag verkligen inte.
Jag fattar.
Men hade du någon bakgrund i någon träning?
Jag har kampsportat i stort sett av och till sedan jag var 13-14.
I olika former, allt som går att kampsporta nästan.
Men väldigt mycket mer av än på.
Nej, jag fattar inte det.
Jag hade inte så långa sammanhängande träningsperioder.
Jag förstår, du var en period där innan kampsport.
Och så gymmade lite, simmade lite, surfade lite.
Okej.
Jag känner ju inte den Anja, jag har ju bara sett dig när du har varit fokuserad.
Ja, jag var väldigt spretig innan det här beslutet.
Okej, men då kom du in och blev du delägare i ett gym.
Ja.
Och jag blev ju då utlovad diverse PT-utbildningar, som jag genomförde.
Tyckte ändå att, ja men det här är jag ju jättebra på.
Jag kände mig fenomenal, som att jag verkligen hade hittat hem.
Jag fattade träning och jag kunde människor och självförtroende var verkligen på topp.
Så jag tog beslutet att köpa in mig i det här företaget.
Och tack och lov då, så rådde min pappa mig.
Att snälla, snälla, snälla, jag kan inte stoppa dig, men anlita en advokat.
Så det gjorde jag och det var ett väldigt bra beslut.
För att det var inte det bästa i investeringen som jag gjort, men det slutade ändå i någonting väldigt bra.
För att jag och övriga delägare, vi gjorde ändå någonting bra av det här till slut.
Det är ett ganska bra råd.
Det är ganska ovanligt att man som 23-åring kanske tänker på den sortens punkter, men det är också ganska vanligt att, det vill säga, samköp inom företag eller att man driver företag ihop blir lyckat.
Även Gymm-kompaniiet har ju en historia i bakgrunden av tre personer som startar ihop och sedan gick skilda vägar innan jag kom in där.
Du har ju gjort samma resa.
Ja, men precis.
Okej, men då kom du in där och sedan var ni ett gäng människor som började.
Då var det inte det gymmet som ni har idag.
Nej, precis.
Vad var det för gym på den tiden?
Det hette Fustra och var specialiserade då på personlig träning och även att utbilda personliga tränare.
Så anläggningen vi hade var ju ett gym på cirka 80 kvadrat som låg ned i våningen av Velitebarkhotell.
Jättefint gym.
Och vi var ju sex personer som jobbade heltid med personlig träning på 80 kvadrat.
Så det var väldigt mycket personlig träning.
Ni var ganska tidiga inom personlig träning.
Nu är ju det, eller kanske för några år sen var det ju väldigt trendigt.
Alla skulle bli PT och det är fortfarande många som vill bli.
Men detta var ju, vad kan det vara, 15 år sedan?
Nästa år är det 15 år igen.
Och då var ju inte PT lika stort på det sättet.
Så det är ganska unikt att kunna ha den sortens heltidsanställda som...
Ja men det var det.
Och Jarko som var väl min mentor på den tiden, han var ju extremt driven när det gällde att både sälja men att coacha tränare till att bli bra säljare och veta hur stor del av yrket det är.
Ja.
Kan du förklara hur stor del av det är?
Du har ändå drivit PT-verksamhet i många år.
Kan du inte, jag har ju varit med lite i din värld så att säga.
Jag vet ju hur svårt detta med säljet är.
Just med personlig träning så skiljer det sig väl lite grann från många andra typer av försäljning i och med att det är ju någonting som måste upprätthållas.
Du måste lägga ditt sälj på en nivå som du kan upprätthålla över tid för att ska du lyckas som PT så säljer du ju självklart initialt för att få in nya kunder, men framförallt så måste du ju bibehålla kvaliteten.
Vilket innebär ju att försäljning är ju en livsservice när du är personligt tränare.
Skulle du säga att det är det folk inte riktigt förstår?
Det är väldigt många PT som sätter igång och så jobbar de kanske ett halvår, kanske ett år, jag tror snarare ett halvår än ett år och sen lägger de ner.
Så kan det nog vara.
Det är också så att många personliga tränare tror ju att de tycker om att träna själva och därför så kommer de bli bra PTS.
Men eftersom vad träning är för olika människor så måste du vara väldigt lyhörd som person.
Du måste tycka att det är väldigt intressant att förstå dig på vad olika individer behöver.
Men jag skulle säga framförallt som ny tränare så behöver du vara beredd på att i stort sett vara bokningsbar från 06.00 till 21.00 måndag till fredag plus några timmar i lörd och söndag.
För att du behöver framförallt kunna jobba när dina kunder vill träna.
Och de kunderna som ofta köper PT kanske har lite mer, ska man säga, de är inte lika flexibla i sitt schema som vissa andra.
Nej, nej så är det.
Och jag såg det som varje gång jag fick in en ny kund, så var ju det som högsta vinsten på lotto.
Jag var helt besatt av att få in nya kunder.
Så jag jobbade väl kanske mellan tio och tolv timmar PT om dagen de första åren.
Och det visste man blev helt slut i huvudet, men det var så himla roligt för jag älskade att få in nya kunder.
Men jobbade du som PT då, eller för du var inte säljare då, du sa tidigare att du blev inne i den branschen på grund av att du var säljaraktig, men du blev ändå PT typ direkt.
Ja, och de går hand i hand.
Men det var inte så att du sålde åt andra utan du sålde från början först och främst till dig själv.
Kan du berätta lite om hur du kom igång med ditt sälj?
Är det bara att gå ut på gatan och säga att du behöver träna lite?
Hur lyckades du ändå få in en, jag vet ju att du har haft en heltid inom PT-världen under många många många många år.
Och det är ganska svårt att bli fullbokad som PT, och framförallt så som du kunde jobba senare där du faktiskt kunde styra dina tider ganska starkt.
Men hur kom du igång från start att bli fullbokad?
Jag mailade och ringde i stort sett alla företag och alla människor som jag kunde hitta i Niro, på Hitta och på Ratsit och på Google och på hemsidor.
Inom typ fem kvadratkilometer runt Elite Wellness, som det hette.
Ja.
Och var väldigt trevlig när jag ringde och sa hej hej, jag har precis börjat jobba här mitt på Avenyn och skulle vilja visa upp vår fantastiska anläggning.
Vill du komma hit, jag bjuder på ett pass.
Så jag satt och ringde och bjöd in.
Och alla jag träffade bjöd in.
Och dessutom, mitt självförtroende var ju i rymden typ, avseende min kompetens som tränare.
Så, jag tyckte ju också att alla borde ju verkligen vilja spendera en timme med mig.
Och det avspeglades ju nog också.
För senare har jag också insett att jag hade ju väldigt mycket kvar att lära som Peter, vilket jag fortfarande har och alltid kommer att ha.
Man lär sig ständigt.
Men, tron på att man är bra på det man gör, och har viljan att fortsätta och bli bättre, det är någonting som avspeglar sig när någon tränar med dig.
Hur många skulle du säga svarade att, ja men det låter som en bra idé, klart jag ska komma ner där.
Kanske en på femtio.
Ja, skönt.
Hur många av dem blev faktiskt kunder, eller bra kunder kanske ska jag säga, som fortsatte komma tillbaka, inte bara ett fempack.
Jag tror att jag behövde väl göra ungefär hundra provtränningar för att få in en kund.
Något mer kanske.
Framförallt ifall det var, om det kom provtränningar på rekommendationer så var det ju oftast säkrare kort.
Men, säger för att få in mina första tre, fyra bra kunder, så behövde jag väl göra kanske 300 provtränningar på totalt random blanka kort.
Ja.
Men det var ju också väl investerade timmar för samtliga av de här tränar ju fortfarande hos mig.
Inte med mig, men på min anläggning.
Ja, det är ju grymt.
Tar lite tid, man får vara beredd.
Ja, det är inte en super romantisk historia att starta upp.
Men framförallt så gäller det ju att vara beredd och jobba i stort sett alla tider på dygnet.
Ni har ju alltid jobbat med en, jag skulle inte säga en dyr pt-kostnad mot kund men den har inte heller varit billig jämfört med vissa större gymm som tar väldigt låga priser.
Har du någonsin varit sugen på att ah, vi sänker priserna här för att få in folk eller har du snarare tänkt att vi ska hålla en prisnivå som vi ändå kan leva på?
Nej, vi ska alltid hålla en prisnivå.
Så har jag tänkt.
Sen så har ju min insikt kring vad jag faktiskt behöver ta betalt kanske inte riktigt funnits där.
Så jag har ju gjort några lite större prishöjningar genom åren också.
Men för femton år sedan så tog vi var vårt lägsta timpris 650 kronor per timme.
Så det var ju fortfarande högt då.
Sen så skulle jag säga att man behöver nog ta, man behöver ta ifrån, när man tror att nu har jag satt rätt pris så kan man lägga på 30% till så kanske det hamnar ungefär rätt.
Man får ju också räkna med att dels är det mycket förberedelse tid man inte får betalt för, dels är det många avbokningar och mycket ombokningar i schemat.
Ja och sen får du inte tala om tiden att få in folk.
Eftersom du behöver lägga 100 timmar för att få in en 100 timmars kund.
Så kan man ju göra matten där.
Ja exakt.
När du gick från att vara PT eller det var i ditt primära jobb där kan man säga, och sen blev det lite mer säljaraktigt kanske, men sedan blev det ju så att du tog över Elite Wellness.
Ja, precis.
Kan du inte berätta lite om den transformationen och hur du upplevde det och hur du tyckte om att vara från, ja, det var din, du fick göra din grej för dig själv till att nu ska jag ta hand om massa personal här och folk ska lyssna på mig.
Lite så var det ju även innan det, såklart, eftersom jag var en av delägarna från början.
Så just beslutet att ta över Elite Wellness helt, det berodde ju mest på att mina övriga delägare ville fokusera mer på PT-skola och internetbaserad träning.
Och jag ville fortsätta att träna kunder.
Så det var ju huvudsaken till varför vi gick skilda vägar.
Men då när jag tog över själv så hade jag väl egentligen ingen affärsplan överhuvudtaget.
Mer än att jag tyckte väldigt mycket om de stunderna i gymmet.
När jag tränade en kund och jag såg att tre, fyra andra också tränade mina kunder.
Och jag insåg att det här är ju också ett sätt att jobba.
Att en mindre procent går till mig när någon annan tränar en kund som jag förvaltar.
Så det var ju egentligen så den vägen startade.
Och också under total förvirring.
För att jag hade ingen aning om hur man skulle motivera andra människor till att göra det här, eller hur man skulle hålla upp en grupp.
Så det var ju då du och jag lärde känna varandra bättre.
Ja men det var ju trevligt.
Joel kom in i bilden och blev vd på...
På typ två möten.
Ja, på julldagen var första mötet.
Så kanske det var det.
Det kan också tilläggas att jag hade ingen aning om heller vad jag höll på med.
Men du var lite mer eftertänksam och balanserad.
Bra, kläm fram en komplimang till här i alla fall.
Lite mer eftertänksam, det kan man inte anställa någon på.
Det är okej, du behöver inte klämma fram en komplimang.
Ja, det är svårt faktiskt att komma på.
Du har ren desperation.
Tack Joel, du var nog en förutsättning till att vi skulle komma vidare till nästa steg.
Ja, i alla fall.
Vi ska inte fastna i sånt där.
Men du gick till att sätta igång ljummet och det hände ganska mycket där under ett par år.
Ni gick från att kanske ha en lite mer splittrad grej ni höll på med lite allt möjligt och sen så gick ni till att bli mer av ett PT-gym.
Kanske fokusera att det var ett gäng som slutade och ett gäng som började och sedan var det en flytt till ett riktigt gym.
Ja, och det här hände ju också för att på Elite Wellness så fanns ju Johanna Fuxborg också som anställdes 2009.
Och vi hade jobbat sida vid sida under hela första tiden.
Men när jag tog över gymdelen och sålde mina första aktier så tog hon över behandlingsdelen.
Och i den här vevan så utbildade hon sig också till yogalärare.
Så vi, ja jag jobbade med PT-delen, hon hade yogaklasser och massagekunder.
Så att vi tillsammans visualiserade ett ställe som fortfarande var specialiserat på personligt träning men där man också kunde träna i mindre grupper med en PT.
Och då började vi leta lokaler helt enkelt i närheten av Elite Wellness för att vi ändå skulle kunna behålla samma känsla för våra kunder och vi ville behålla vårt klientel och den exklusiva känslan som fanns på Elite Wellness.
Så då kom Eminent Hälsostudio till.
Ja, kan du inte beskriva det lite?
Ja, vi hittade en lokal och skrev på ett hyresavtal och fick den här nattklubben att byggas om till ett gym.
Vi kan ju säga att den ligger mitt på avenyn.
Ja, det gör den.
Vad hette Comroa, den gamla nattklubben heter?
Det har varit typ sju nattklubbar där, men när du och jag var yngre så hette den Excellent.
Även Wide Corner, Harrys.
Jag vet att jag har varit där och mått illa någon gång i alla fall.
Ja, jag har faktiskt trillat ner från trappan en gång och blivit av med ett falsk lägg.
Ja.
Det är okej, jag har säkert spytt på en toalett där så att det är...
Ja, men det blev ett fancygym helt enkelt.
Det blev det.
Det är jättefint och det är hundra procent tack vare Johanna som det är fint för att hon är jätteduktig på inredning.
Hon är den estetiska.
Åh ja.
Ska man säga att nu när jag och min flickvän blev ihop så presenterade jag ju dig och då hade jag ju pratat om dig som, ja men hon kör kampsport och hon är såhär, ja hon säger såhär och pratar såhär och gör såhär.
Så att hon hade ju en bild av att du var någon sorts butch, björnkvinna från Ryssland till Hälsa.
Men det är inte riktigt så du ser ut.
Men hon tänkte ju det.
Men jag skulle ändå säga att det kanske inte är, det är ju inte, i eran du och din och Johannas du och det är ju ni som ägde ljummet när ni flyttade över där, då är ju hon den lite mer vänna, den lite mer estetiska, det ska vara fint och det ska vara tyst och lugnt här.
Hon har en joagaröst och tände ljus och vi kompletterar varandra, så kan man väl säga.
Ja, det får man ändå säga.
Men kan du inte beskriva varför ni ändå valde att köra på med hela den här PT?
Jag skulle vilja höra lite mer om hur det har varit att jobba med tränare och massörer.
Det är ett ganska personaltätt gym jämfört med många gyms som idag rör sig mot att automatisera din logga.
Man ska bara komma in, det finns ingen personal alls.
Ni är ju på helt andra spektrumet.
Det är ju väldigt personligt att se det.
Det är, man kan väl säga såhär, hade jag köttat på bara som PT, då hade ju min personliga ekonomiska resa sett mycket bättre ut tidigare.
För när man startar upp en anläggning, och då inte bara avseende hyror och inventari och annat, och här ska då tilläggas att vi tog inga lån för att starta upp, utan alla pengar som vi fick in i bolaget investerade vi då i den nya lokalen för att, ja men egentligen, kunna starta upp skuldfria.
Vilket är ju kanon, men då får man ju också vara väldigt kreativ med lösningar på hur man ska inreda och göra annat.
Men sen så är det också så att det innebär ju väldigt stora kostnader med personal, givetvis.
Och man måste ta hand om sin personal.
Likväl som man tar hand om sina kunder, så är du personligt tränare och har personal.
Så måste du tänka väldigt mycket på hur andra människor mår hela tiden.
Och det är jätteroligt men väldigt, väldigt svårt också.
Det är många svåra stunder men samtidigt väldigt, väldigt roligt.
Så nu är jag väldigt glad över hur resan har gått och var vi har hamnat.
Men det har ju varit extremt tufft längs vägen och jag har säkert gjort jättedåliga beslut längs vägen och kanske absolut inte varit den bästa ledaren.
För det är ju utmanande.
Ja, och du har ju heller inte alltid, eller ganska sällan kanske enbart jobbat som chef eller vad vi ska säga, utan du har ju ganska ofta gjort, du har jobbat som PT vid sidan av eller säljare vid sidan av, du har ju ganska sällan haft fullt fokus på.
Ja, fram till 2019 så jobbade jag ju heltid som personligtränare och personalchef, ekonomichef, administrationschef, finanschef.
Varav allt förutom personligtränare var ju sådant som jag absolut inte hade någon aning om hur någonting funkade.
Som tur är så har jag haft jättebra människor omkring mig.
Jag har haft diverse, både mentorer och människor omkring mig som jag kan fråga som varit väldigt stöttande längs vägen.
Så ska man göra en sån här grej så är det väldigt bra att ha människor omkring sig som man litar på och kan få både bra och dåliga råd ifrån.
För att du kommer få alla sorter så det gäller att testa och våga lämna något som inte funkar och gå vidare när någonting funkar.
Nu pratar ju du ganska ötmjukt här men jag vet ju att Eminent har en del exklusive avtal som är jämfört med andra gym i alla fall ligger väldigt högt i pris.
Vad ligger er dyraste paket på idag?
Får man säga det?
Ja okej, vad ligger det dyraste officiella paketet på som man kan se på hemsidan?
Det finns inte med på hemsidan.
Okej, men det ligger ganska högt i pris i alla fall.
Skulle man kunna säga, det ligger ju norr om 100 000 för ett helår.
Ja, väldigt norr om det.
Ja, bara så att folk får någon sorts uppfattning om hur klientelet, eller hur utbudet ser ut.
Men vad skulle du säga är det som gör att ni ändå lyckas behålla de här kunderna år efter år efter år.
För det finns ju många kunder där som har varit kunder där under väldigt lång tid och som bara, ja men som tar med liksom familjen dit eller som gör det till, det här är en del av deras livsstil.
Det är väl den aspekten som vi är inne på från början att just försäljning av personlig träning är, det är ju personligt.
Så att du måste alltid ha med hjärtat i det du gör.
Och du måste tro på det du gör, men framförallt så måste du vara väldigt lyhörd, du måste finnas där.
Det, och hålla samma nivå som du gick in med, måste du fortsätta hålla över tid.
Och jag tror att det är det som kan vara den svåra biten.
Och livet kommer ju emellan ibland.
Jag har tävlat, jag har haft relationsdraman, familjedraman, jag har fått barn, massa situationer i livet som kanske påverkar vad jag kan leverera.
Men då får man ju ha en dialog med sina kunder och försöka lösa det på bästa sätt.
Så jag tror att det som har gjort, att vi har kunnat behålla så många kunder under 15 års tid, är för att vi, både jag och Johanna och våra anställda, är väldigt måna om dialog med våra kunder och att fortsätta leverera våra tjänst.
Även ifall man kommer nära för att man lär känna varandra, så måste man göra skillnad på att nu är det här din timme och jag finns här för dig och nu fokuserar vi på detta.
Ska vi prata om någonting annat så får vi ta en lunch eller ta en kaffe efter träningen till exempel.
Ja, jag skulle säga att som utomstående så har det varit väldigt tydligt att du haft fokus på att det är kunden som gäller under den stunden kunden är där.
Om man lyssnar på kunden och jag har ju sett dig upprörd eller irriterad ganska hårt ett fåtal gånger när tränare eller någon kanske har gjort bort sig lite mot en kund eller man har inte varit på plats när kunden har kommit eller man har tagit med sig humöret och det är så det behöver vara.
Alltså man behöver ju, när man är på plats då är man på liksom.
Då är man där för kunden.
Ja och det är, jag tycker att personligt träning är en otroligt viktig tjänst för att träning, man kan förändra människors liv med personligt träning.
Väldigt liten del av personligt träning, framförallt personligt träning, inte träning i sig men personligt träning handlar om fysiska mål eller tävlingar eller större prestationer utan det kan handla om att förbättra någons livskvalitet på riktigt.
Och då är det ganska små justeringar men de måste vara varaktiga, långsiktiga och hålla samma nivå hela tiden.
Jaha, du är ju kampsportare, eller du har varit kampsportare, jag vet inte hur mycket du är kampsportare idag.
Ja men faktiskt, typ en dag i veckan.
Alltså ja okej, ja fan det är bra.
Det är ändå hyggligt, jag vet inte jag gör situationstecken, är det riktig kampsport?
Jag kör ju med Jonas Jensen, i hans garage, så pucklar vi på varandra.
Vi kan väl ge en shout out till Jonas här, om man inte vet vem det är så är det ju en tränare som han får alla att känna sig som att de är bäst i världen.
Verkligen.
Det hade han när jag var nybörjare och har aldrig känt mig så bra som under de passen när han höll mids.
Han är väldigt duktig på att få en att känna sig duktig.
Som en champion.
Ja, så är det.
Det är också farligt för då tror man att man kan gå match och spö alla.
Ja, men självförtroende kommer man långt med.
Ja.
Men det jag tänkte säga är att du har ju sysslat mycket med kampsport.
Hur har det varit att ta in den bakgrunden in i den här exklusiva, vackra PT-miljön?
För det är ändå ganska uppskattat bland kunderna där.
Oh ja.
Jo men precis, jag menar, yoga är ju superflumigt, det kan vara.
Att man kommer in i ett rum och plötsligt folk säger aong.
Ja.
Är det så hur yoga ser ut att se ut?
Johanna får skriva in och klaga.
Men kontrastet i vardagen är ju alltid roligt.
Och det är ju få saker som är så roligt som att få sätta på sig i bokssanskar och släppa lösenergi och lära sig saker som man...
För kampsport är ju en...
Alla har en relation till det på något sätt för att man har...
Och åtminstone jag slogs som barn på skolgården och sådär.
Det är skönt att du förutsätter att alla gjorde det.
Men alla har en relation till det.
Sen så är ju inte kampsport som många tror.
Man får ju förändra bilden lite av att det är aggressivt och smutsigt på något sätt.
För det kan ju vara som en konstform, jättevackert och jätteroligt.
Jag menar, skulle du och jag köra på så kanske det hade sett jättefarligt ut.
Men eftersom vi känner till ungefär hur varandras nivå ligger till och vet om viktskillnad och annat, så går det ju att anpassa på ett sätt som gör att det blir ganska roligt för båda två.
Ja, framförallt är det ju en ganska, eller oftast i alla fall, en ganska respektfull miljö.
Jag har ju köpt många sporter och det har ju varit betydligt mycket mer bullshit inom många.
Sen finns det mycket bullshit inom kampsport också, såklart.
Men jag bara menar att ofta blir det en ganska god kameratskap och man respekterar varandra trots att man slår på varandra lite grann.
Ja, exakt.
Sen så är ju motionsformen ännu mer förfinad såklart.
Men det som jag gör med mina kunder är ju otroligt uppskattat och har inte alls varit konstigt att implementera i den miljön, även ifall det har funnits ett vitt motstånd kanske från början, så när det är ingen som har provat det som inte har velat fortsätta.
Du hade ju en viss, ska vi kalla det, karriär inom kampsporten då, när du i alla fall tävlade aktivt.
Varför valde du att sluta med det?
Dels så får jag väl kanske skylla på att jag började satsa när jag var lite väl gammal.
Så jag gick ju mina sista matcher när jag var 33 och då var jag väl egentligen som bäst.
Och då höll inte riktigt kroppen så som jag hade önskat.
Så jag fick, hade pajat båda knäna, enaxen.
Det var liksom inte roligt att preppa inför matcher med massa roddande runt omkring skadorna.
Jag vet att inför, det var Asia Open, så satt jag på golvet och körde battle ropes för att hålla konditionen ihop för att jag kunde inte göra någonting stor.
Du kunde inte stå uppe, ja.
Det blev silver där ändå, men det var, i ringen så fick jag ställa mig och ta mig knäskydden som tydligen inte var godkända för att ta inne på match.
Det blev lite, ja, så skador och hög ålder, är det då?
Ja, det är bra.
Jag skyller på samma sak.
Under hela den här resan som du har gjort här, från att du gick från, ja, kaféet kan vi säga, till att börja som PT, till att sälja, till att ta över där som vd och ägare ihop med Johanna och flytten till Eminent.
Sedan kan man väl säga, utvecklat din ledarroll här på Eminent.
Nu jobbar du väl ändå som vd, inte så mycket som PT längre.
Gör du någon PT idag?
Nej, men jag håller ett boxningspass i veckan.
Okej, det är bra.
Det är ungefär lagom.
Vad har varit svårast under hela den här resan?
Eller vilka moment har varit svårast?
Ska läggas till att hon sitter och tänker, nu är jag riktigt fokuserad.
Det kommer inga såhär bullshit vanliga svar.
Jaha, det svåraste har ju varit, utan det är ändå eftertänksamma svar här, det uppskattar vi.
Det svåraste...
Och du får inte säga allt?
Nej, nej, nej.
Det svåraste är personal.
Ja.
Kunder är alltså...
Att träna kunder är jätteroligt och jättehärligt.
Även att få in och behålla försäljningen är jättekul och så.
Men personal är nog svårast.
Också på grund av att man som ledare, så kommer man ju nära personer i sin omgivning.
Men där blir det på något sätt också att ifall jag har personliga utmaningar, så måste jag ju lägga det åt sidan också.
Ifall någon av personalen har personliga utmaningar.
Vilket man alltid har.
Ja, men personal och ekonomi då.
Jag är ju M&M's finanschef.
Och det finns jättemånga här i världen som är väldigt mycket bättre på det än vad jag är.
Så det kan skrämma mig lite att jag är sista ledet.
Men jag har lärt mig otroligt mycket under åren.
Och tycker att det är väldigt, väldigt roligt.
Det är det svåraste och det roligaste.
Jag skulle säga att både personal och den ekonomiska biten är både det svåraste och det roligaste.
Och det är väl det som gör att det blir intressant att fortsätta.
För annars hade jag nog tröttnat och velat gå vidare med någonting annat.
Men jag tycker fortfarande att det är jättestimulerande och det finns så mycket att lära sig.
Kan du uppleva en frustration i att PT-branschen är ju, och även Massörer, och ni har ju hela spektrat givetvis, men kan du uppleva en frustration över att man lär upp en person, man lär dem träning, man lär dem försäljning, ni jobbar ju mycket med era tränare, och så är det ju ofta så att folk kanske gör detta under en viss begränsad tidsperiod och sen går vidare.
Det blir ju lite en in-ut bransch på många sätt.
Det är ju många som har gått vidare genom åren.
Ja, det är faktiskt inte så mycket.
I de allra flesta fall så har jag haft bara förståelse för att folk vill gå vidare och tycker att det är ganska roligt.
För alla har ju sin livsresa, och det är inte bra för någon om någon stannar och inte är nöjd med vad man gör eller situationen.
Många av våra huvudspelare har ju jobbat hos oss mellan 5-8 år, vilket är ganska länge i norrbranschen.
Där vi har haft störst rolljans har vi varit på sådana som har jobbat extra med diverse pass, framförallt i gruppträning.
Det finns så många duktiga inom branschen, så det har varit ganska lätt att hålla en rotation där.
Sedan tog jag faktiskt in en ny delägare, för nästa år blir det tre år, Petter Malmberg.
Det var till viss del för att jag verkligen ville behålla honom.
Han har jobbat hos oss länge och är en väldigt uppskattad person bland oss och våra kunder, så då har det varit ett steg för honom att utvecklas vidare och få en ny roll inom bolaget också.
Så nej, jag tycker att det är absolut man investerar mycket i att lära upp en ny person, men så kommer det vara inom alla jobb.
Skulle du säga att det finns några highlight-ögonblick inom den här resan som har varit helt kritiska för att ni skulle faktiskt fortsätta eller överleva eller utvecklas?
Ja men jag skulle säga dina år som vd.
Vad räknas till dag?
Flytten till Eminent Hälsostudio.
Våra nya lokaler, absolut.
Det är ganska stora händelser, man behöver inte.
Nej, det är nog våra superhighlights.
Och det som blev den stora grejen när ni flyttade till Eminent blev väl framför allt att här fick ni bestämma och här fick ni, innan var ni i lite studier av hotellet, alltså man var ju ändå fast i deras miljö.
Här är det ju era miljö, det är ni som sätter hela standarden för allt helt enkelt.
Och att vi kunde sälja medlemskap, addera det till vårt utbud.
Hur stor andel är medlemskap idag kontra PT-massage, jag vet inte om ni har en naprapat idag också, och liknande yoga?
Nej, inte just nu inte naprapat men personlig träning utgör ungefär 85% av våra omsättningar.
Ja, det är rätt grustiga.
Det andra har en mindre fördelning.
Jag förstår.
Men dock så viktig.
På något sätt så är det ju ganska många som kanske kör PTX antal gånger i månaden som vill ha en massage.
Precis, det tillför mer världen på så många sätt.
Och sen så blir det ju också massage.
Vi får ju in fler nya massagekunder och det blir ju också en introduktion till personligt träning.
Och avseende medlemskapen så är det ju också ett sätt för någon som kanske bara vill köra PTX en gång i månaden, vill ändå ha sin tränare men går då på ett PT-smallgrupppass till exempel.
Och PT-smallgrupppassen utgör ju också en garanterad intäkt för våra tränare så de vet att den ligger vecka för vecka.
Det blir en grund att gå in och starta på, eftersom man kanske inte går in och har en grund med PT-kunder när man börjar.
Har du några tips till...
Det finns ju ganska många gym som har försökt få igång PT.
Det var ju många av de stora gymmen som verkligen gjorde en del satsningar för några år sedan.
Men PT har ju lite trappat ner, det är väldigt många som har svårt att få lönsamhet i det eller faktiskt får det att funka.
Har du några tips om att så här får man igång en PT-verksamhet att funka?
Oj, ja alltså om det är som personligen då som tränare, så är det ju tillgänglighet.
Du behöver vara beredd på att jobba väldigt långa upphackade dagar.
Och det kanske inte är så man ska säga men så är det.
Enligt mig så måste du vara beredd och jobba väldigt långa upphackade dagar.
Kanske gå och sova lite i personalrummet när du har en paus.
Och sen så såklart bibehålla kvalitet över tid.
Det du levererar på första passet ska du också leverera på det 512e passet.
Hur har ni jobbat med PTS när man tänker lönemässigt, eftersom det är ju en ganska spretig, får man betalt per timme man utför, eller har man en arbetsdag, eller hur ser kompensationsmodellen ut?
Det är lite olika, ofta så har det väl varit per timme.
Men sen så har vi testat varianter med att det finns en grundlön och så får man extra när man är bokad.
Och det finns vissa som jobbar så fortfarande, men då får man ju vara kreativ med andra arbetsuppgifter.
Då får man ju jobba med att vika handdukar, hålla fint i gymmet och sälja och göra andra saker som behövs på ett gym.
Det är ju en anläggning som ska hållas igång.
Vad skulle du säga är den bästa modellen?
Finns det någon som du säger, det här tror jag.
Jag förstår att man försöker anpassa till sin personal, man försöker hitta lösningar, men vad tror du är den bästa kompensationsmodellen?
Det finns inte.
Låt säga att jag skulle bli anställd någonstans, så hade den bästa kompensationsmodellen för mig varit att jag bara får betalt per pt-timme.
För att jag hade köttat på med pt-timmar.
Men det finns andra som kanske prioriterar hellre en stabilare vardag.
För det är också så att om någon vill ha en grundlön och extra för pt-timmar så kommer timlönan vara lägre än för en person som bara får betalt för sina pt-timmar.
Så vill du hellre ha en lite mer trygghet så kommer du vara beredd på att du kommer att få lite lägre ersättning.
Och är du beredd på att ha betalt timme för timme då kommer du potentiellt kunna tjäna mer.
Men du tar ju också en större risk.
Så det beror mer på individen, vad som är bäst.
Ni har ju hamnat i, jag känner Johanna och Petter också.
Johanna har ju två barn idag och du har ju ett barn idag.
Vi väntar på Petter sedan han klämmer fram något snart.
Men jag tror att det är en situation som uppstår för ganska många inom där man driver ett gym.
För att driva ett gym, oavsett om det är PT eller att driva ett gym så är det ofta ganska personligt.
Du driver ju ofta gymmet i egen regi, om du inte ingår i en kedja då.
Men till alla de som driver gym därute i Sverige så har de ju ofta gymmet på egen hand.
De är där tidigt att öppna, de är där att stänga i, de känner alla kunder.
När ni fick barn, eller när ni har gått igenom den första perioden, eller hur har ni hanterat det mot kunderna, relaterat till hur personlig er business faktiskt är?
Hur har ni löst det?
Ja alltså så här då, när Johanna var gravid första gången, det var ju jätteroligt.
Och hallelujah, superkul.
Och hon var mammaledig i ett år.
Och allting funkade jättebra.
Och jag var verkligen såhär, ta det lugnt Johanna, ta din tid.
Och kunderna var jätteglada för hennes skull.
Och allting var hallelujah.
Känns det som det kommer ett män här?
Ja.
För när Hilde är typ ett år så ska Johanna, hon var hemma hos mig och jag bara, vin är det öl?
Och hon bara, jag bara nej nej nej nej nej nej nej nej.
Hon bara jo.
Det var inte meningen.
Jag bara okej, hade ni skydd?
Nej men asså.
Jag bara tänker att vi kommer att imponera att det är sakta sexliv här.
I alla fall.
Jag sa, jag är jätteglad för din skull, men nu var det egentligen min tur nästa gång.
Så det här är också någonting man kan vara beredd på när man har partners, för man förliter ju sig väldigt mycket på varandra.
Det är som att man inte styr deras liggagenda.
Nej, exakt.
Man kan tycka att man ska få göra det.
Ja, jag förstår ju det här.
Men det blev väldigt bra ändå, för i den här vevan så tog jag in Petter som delägare.
Och Johanna har gjort ett helt mirakulöst jobb, för att när Bob var tre månader, alltså barn två, så gick hon tillbaks och jobbade, jag kan inte räkna i tid, men hon har jobbat jättemycket sedan Bob var tre månader.
Och hur hon har lyckats få ihop det här med två barn, är för mig helt obegripligt.
Men där är det också att kunderna, eftersom vi känner våra kunder, hon har bra dialog med alla och så, så har det varit att hon får styra om lite, eller ta med sig bebisen, så har det funkat.
Men sen när ni båda hade barn, hur har ni hanterat?
För innan kan ni ändå täcka upp lite, eller du kan täcka upp lite för henne, men hur har ni löst det nu?
När jag då blev gravid, så började jag planera för det här, samma dag som det var ett plus, så började jag planera för hur ska det här gå ihop.
Så jag flyttade hem allt som jag behövde ha för att göra alla administration.
Och började jobba hemifrån så som jag trodde att det skulle funka att jobba.
Ah, testkörde lite.
Ja, så man kan säga att de sista sex månaderna av graviditeten, så som jag jobbade då, har jag fortsatt jobba sen Ophelia föddes.
Och nu då när hon har börjat förskola, så har jag börjat komma tillbaks på plats.
Sen så absolut, hon var faktiskt med på lite personalmöten och så där i början, men jag har i stort sett jobbat hemma med det jag har behövt.
Och då har ju också Petter och Johanna tagit väldigt mycket av det som behövs göras på plats.
Så det har funkat väldigt, väldigt bra.
Okej, ja vad skönt.
Jag tänker bara avslutande, har du några, det går ju lite in i kanske hur man gör som PTM, men om man bara tänker rent allmänt i träningsvärlden, har du några tips till den som faktiskt vill kunna jobba på att, eller kunna leva på att jobba inom tränningsvärlden?
Det finns ju ganska många som försöker och som vill in i den här världen, men det är en svår värld, det är inte så höga marginaler, det är mycket passionsdrivet och det är lätt att gå vidare.
Ja men från början, ta betalt så mycket som du behöver, ta betalt, bygg inget luftslott på för låga priser och sådär, utan se till att ta betalt så som du vill ha betalt.
Och sen jobba dig upp till den kvaliteten istället.
Ja, var beredd på att du kommer behöva jobba extremt långa dagar under ganska många år.
Jag skulle säga att innan du kommer till nivån, åtminstone som persontränare, där du kan jobba mellan 09-15, fullbokad, då kanske du får blicka fem, sex, sju år fram.
Och innan dess så kanske du får ihop sex timmar på femton timmar.
Och du ska vara glad över det.
Varenda jag ställer den här frågan till alla, men det är en jävla deppig fråga med alla.
Alla säger ungefär samma sak.
Får du en avslutning alltid med en deppig avslutning att bli läkare istället.
Ja, det var långa övrigt som kom med.
Det är svårt för alla, det finns ingenstans.
Jättebra, men jag tror att det är ett sunt och korrekt råd.
Ja, då går man in med öppna ögon i alla fall, då kanske man blir positivt överraskad.
Ja, jag får säga ett stort tack till Anja som var med i podden och ett fantastiskt avsnitt.
Tack själv, hej hej.
Tack, tack, hej.
Det är okej, jag har säkert spytt på en toalett där.